Này 20 năm tăng tâm người, Mala Xia đã chính thức chuyển ra chức chụt tịch bôi của cây đồng nâma ASEAN,
Charles Philippines tại lấy bếm mạng của người cấp cao ASEAN, tổ chức ở thủ đô của là lắm bờ.
Chào mỗi lẽ, thủ tâm Mala Xia, and Wai Ibrahim, chào biểu tưởng chụt tịch, chào tổng thống Philippines,
Ferry Nang, Macros Junior, đánh dấu sự kết thúc nhận kỳ chụt tức nâng anh em không chào em làm của Mala Xia,
và mở đồng dưới đoạn lãnh đạo mới của Philippines trong nâng em, chào em sau.
Tổng thống Macros Junior vài tỏ nghiệm phíng sử và phòng đệm.
Tế lipein sẽ tìm nối những hình quả đặt đuộc tập chung được kẻ tâm nghiệm tổng đồng ASEAN,
2.5 tơi nâng anh em không chào mỗi lắm, với tựa tiền về kinh tế anh em và hợp tắc của bật.
Nha lạnh đạo Philippines cũng nhận mạnh cảm kế thổ chở,
thì Mala Xia chúng có chình ra nhập đầy đủ ASEAN.
Cái đầy là bức đi quan chào phương tối một tổng đồng của bật thống nhất, năng đạo và bình bứng hơn.
Theo dưới qua xãi, bởi tất cả các là chủ tịch ASEAN, Philippines sẽ gánh văn vài cho của khuối cho bật để anh em hảnh hại,
推 qua miệng mà cũng nhiều uống tiền khác.